let's talk about the elephant in the
room here megan and harry they got one
line reference of the speech perfectly
warm um but one line i want to express
my love for harry and megan as they
continue to build their lives overseas
let's just let's just hear him on the
man himself king charles
as my heir
william
now assumes the scottish titles which
have meant so much to me
he succeeds me as duke of cornwall with
catherine beside him
our new prince and princess of wales
will i know
continue to inspire and lead our
national conversations
helping to bring the marginal to the
center ground
where vital help can be given
i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
what i thought was interesting uh tom
you've just written this excoriating
book about meghan markle um
you know
he spent a lot of time painstakingly
painting in the new picture of life with
his heir william and all these titles
and he gets to harry there's no title
there's no duke and duchess of sussex
it's just harry and megan
making me wonder if he is contemplating
something his mother didn't want to do
in her
dotage at the end
i'll be reaching a point where charles
could actually take their titles away if
he feels that the drip drip drip damage
of the way they've been exploiting them
for personal gain becomes too much to
sustain for the weight well i i i think
that his uh reference was safeguarding i
mean charles's great
threat uh to his monarchy is the
biography and megan doing more
interviews like she did last week right
of the cut you mean harry harry's book
harry's book the biography i mean that's
going to be devastating for the royal
family because that's the only way that
harry could make his income i was told
this week that charles is incredibly
hurt by what's happened with harry and
megan
but he doesn't understand it he feels he
walked her down the aisle at the wedding
he did everything he could do and he's
now being painted as the bad guy that
camilla may be coming in for the
criticism from harry's book or some kind
of revenge he feels for his mother and
so on which could be incredibly badly
timed for camilla just when her public
standing has never been higher actually
due to 17 years of dutiful work at
charles's side you know this they're
just like these renegade royals running
around absolutely without any sense of
real duty
who just want to make money and attack
the royals well i think that's
absolutely right but i think the
the auspices are bad because um harry
was clearly forced to pay for his own
fare up to scotland yeah he was told he
had to make his own way home so he flew
commercially
did you see uh william and charles this
morning i doubt it and he's been living
down in windsor in football college 500
yards exactly william without even
saying hello i mean it's extremely i
can't
knowing what they used to be like those
two yeah it is incredible how deep this
rift well
there is one element there's one grist
what has caused all this mega marco
exactly yeah and uh she loves it she
loves the publicity she seems to thrive
on familial drama she's disowned all her
own family her dad everything else and
now she's dragged harry away from
herself
are we painting her unfairly son well no
i think in a sense it depends
fair in this case
her sole existence in life depends on
the royal family yes um it is her asset
yes the asset i think the more she draws
it down by being rude about them the
more um
it'll it'll it shall suffer and i think
she'll it'll be like that you can touch
the windows way back they'll fade into
the back but they that once they left
those two walla simpson uh and they
didn't attack the monarchy they didn't
you know give horrible interviews
chipping away calling them a bunch of
callus races i mean they just left all
right he abdicated it was all full blah
blah blah but they didn't continue to be
this running saw the issue i think
charles is going to have with his own
son now he's king this is his son and
his daughter-in-law who is now
referenced in his first speech as king
if they continue to just run around
spray gunning the royals attacking the
monarchy and the very institution itself
where does this take it
but it it diminishes its force the more
it's used it's all going to be history
they don't not to be allowed any new
material so to speak uh and they're
going to be drawing down on that old
material
when they're inventing materials they're
inventing this that's the real danger
well i thought today was very
interesting because
lots more books
honestly i read the whole it's a
fantastic book but the the two they're
two kids for example you may remember
the oprah winfrey interview esther that
meghan markle tried to paint a story
which was that the reason archie the son
had not been made a prince was because
of his skin color and today he becomes a
prince because it was always the case
that that would happen that would happen
once the queen had died and charles
became king had nothing to do with skin
color but this is something immediately
we have the two allegations in the over
interview of race one who was an unnamed
member of the royal family
expressed concern over the boy's skin
potential skin color they couldn't even
decide what year this conversation was
supposed to have happened uh harry and
megan now the other allegation has been
as we knew at the time
obviously was complete nonsense because
today is a prince so yeah we have this
woman biracial spraying race smears at
the royal family that they can't really
respond to none of which appear to be
true but this is the thing she's she she
enjoys the chaos because i i often said
you know if you're leveling these
allegations that someone in the royal
family for making racist remarks name
the person because as an adult it's
completely immature for you to
effectively paint an entire family an
institution as racist without naming the
person unless you thrive on the chaos
you thrive on tarnishing the reputation
of the royal family and you know the
last time jeremy clarkson putting his
column in the sun that he he'd been told
it wasn't even a direct member of the
royal family but this is who said this
this concerning comment but i just
remember that harry and megan they were
two years apart on their timeline i mean
tommy you're the authority on this they
were two years apart in the same
interview about whether winfrey totally
failed to pick up she did yeah she just
let them spew their life what you look
you know all about them what's going to
happen here how does charles manage
these renegades well i do i disagree
with disagree with them my good friend
simon i don't think it'll be history
they will
they can only profit and survive by
inventing smears inventing lies and the
truth is that charles will find it
impossible to reply because what can you
say yeah i don't think that he can
withdraw their titles they'll look
petulant why would i know that actually
why not you can't take the prince of
harry's birthright he's a prince why not
well because it doesn't work
they can't use hrh in public well it
doesn't matter and that didn't matter at
all but take away duke and duchess i
come from sussex i've spent more time in
sussex in the last week than meghan
markle spent there in her life
apparently she's been in the county for
five hours yeah right
i resent the fact that my county where i
grew up she is the she's the duchess of
sussex but she appears really be
realistic
if we take if we take the title it won't
stop her talking no but what it does do
it stops them being able to trade as
royal she could only trade which is
where their real currencies can only
trade as a royal if the american public
respond to it if the american public say
they're not proper royals and they
silence them if congressmen and senators
didn't take her call this is the duchess
of sussex